congratulations on successfully
finishing the summer online training
environment the purpose of the Onix
logic programs is to learn about the
various Onix data types
etiquette unguided experience utilizing
by informatics analysis methods on the
multi Onix tion four platform the next
step is to apply these skills to a
project of your own if you are
interested to continue utilizing the
cloud-based tools you had a chance to
use in this program we're offering a
number of different licensing options
the cost of the licensing goes into the
maintenance of the platforms and towards
the sustainability of this program for
further research development and
improvement the basic membership is best
suited for students interested to
continue to learn about the various
omics technologies and see how
bioinformatics is used in biotechnology
healthcare agriculture and in basic
research the basic membership provides
access to all the a synchronous online
courses on our educational portal with
individual or certification this
membership will also help participants
to continue accessing both a theoretical
and the hands-on courses on
next-generation sequencing data analysis
the same license enables participants to
access or a I guided t financial
platform to run pipelines use machine
learning and complete unlimited practice
pipelines this license does not allow
you to upload any new project data the
educational licenses start at $75 per
month and will give you access to all of
the available courses and projects on
the educational platform as long as you
continue with the license which is
renewed every 30 days the license will
allow you to work on curated educational
datasets uploaded on the platform and
public domain data sets like NCBI or
TCGA if you are enrolled in one of our
online onyx logic programs you will have
an educational license activated as soon
as you are enrolled the educational
license is great for those who want to
practice the next-generation sequencing
data analysis and the
data science skills to learn from and
develop strategies that are implemented
on the educational teaming for projects
in the various areas of research the
research license is aimed at anyone who
is currently utilizing next-generation
sequencing data or any kind of other big
biomedical data in their research the
research license for academia is
available starting at $99 per month for
first time users we offer licenses for a
minimum of three months the research
license provides you with full access to
transcriptomics metagenomics genomics
epigenomics mass spectrometry structural
biology machine learning and
mathematical modeling data analysis
related pipelines
the research license will give you
access to your own personal account
where you can manage your files using
the ftp with five terabytes of space for
personal research projects that you can
upload and priority access to our
high-performance computing
infrastructure we will also get our
support and training from our
experienced staff beyond just purchasing
a license to use some of our tools we
also offer mentorship research
fellowship and internship options online
internship programs are designed to help
young researchers and students take
advantage of the bioinformatics
resources for analysis of complex
high-throughput life science data and
become versed in buying from attics this
internship will allow you to see
bioinformatics research in a context of
a project and offers an opportunity to
become a lifetime member of our growing
by informatics community the internship
program will offer a combination of
online resources and mentor guidance to
prepare you and help you complete a
bioinformatics project currently the
internship requires each student to pay
for the cloud resources including the
access to the powerful and user-friendly
t byron 4 platform we encourage you to
reach out to us directly about the
length and focus of the research
fellowship and internship programs
we appreciate the feedback you provided
for the program resources and online
course work that you had a chance to
complete in this program we hope that
you enjoyed it and learn from the two
weeks we had together we are looking
forward to hearing about your experience
and coordinate your next steps to help
you grow in your professional and
academic journey